À travers les époques les dangers,
une grande aventure les appelle !
C'est (c'est c'est) L'Épopée Temporelle !
Narrateur : La seconde guerre mondiale,
Berlin sous les bombes des alliés, des soldats nazis à tous les coins de rue.
N'est-ce pas le meilleur endroit où atterrir pour nos personnages ?
Eliott le robot, Iris la voyageuse temporelle
Et Thomas le...
Thomas quoi. Se rapprochent des traces du docteur Simon, porté disparu.
Iris : Putain de nazis de merde !
Thomas : Ah ouais, je comprends mieux pourquoi t'étais pas très emballée par cette époque...
Parce que c'est la guerre.
Eliott : Fuyons la zone de combats, par ici.
Thomas : Oooh, ils ont tout fait comme dans Call of Duty, n'empêche.
Iris : Mais t'es vraiment trop con...
Bon attendez faut que j'fasse un truc avec ma robe là,
c'est hyper chiant pour se déplacer.
On enlève les manches,
Hop !
Thomas, prends le bout de verre là et raccourcis moi la robe.
Thomas : Euh... Ok. Ouais euh ok d'accord.
*déchire la robe*
Iris : Attends mais.. t'es sérieux là ? C'est beaucoup trop court !
Thomas : Bah euh... je sais pas, dans les mangas c'est la longueur normale.
Eliott : Maintenant ce sera plus pratique pour te déplacer.
Iris : C'est pour mater mon cul ouais ! Bon, il me reste plus qu'à changer de pompes...
Ah ben tiens, je vais prendre celles du monsieur là ! Elles sont un peu grandes mais ça va le faire.
Thomas : Iris, ce sont les chaussures d'un soldat mort. T'as vu ça ?
Iris : Et maintenant, c'est les miennes !
*Enfile les chaussures*
Ah ben voilà, on est mieux là.
Eliott : Le diadème de reine sur ta tête va te gêner aussi...
Iris : Ah non, non ça je le garde, hein.
C'est trop stylé !
Soldat : Là ! Des intrus ! Vous, qui êtes vous ?
Thomas : Hum.. ben euh.. m-moi c'est Thomas...
Eliott : Chers soldats, on s'est perdu sur le champ de bataille.
Nous sommes berlinois, nous parlons parfaitement Allemand, vous entendez ?
Thomas : Ah non mais moi je parle pas du tout un seul mot d'Allemand-
Iris : Ta gueule !
Soldat : Oui vous avez raison, votre Allemand est parfait.
Vous n'avez rien à faire ici ! La ville est à feu et à sang !
Allez vous mettre à l'abri ! HEIL HITLER !
Iris et Thomas : Heil Hilter... *bafouillages*
(Musique)
Thomas : Vous avez entendu ? Je parle très bien Allemand en fait, j'avais pas remarqué...
Eliott : Pas du tout, je possède un traducteur actif qui traduit toutes les langues dans un large périmètre.
C'est pour ça que le soldat pensait qu'on parlait Allemand.
Iris : Tu t'es pas demandé pourquoi les Anglais te parlaient en Français tout à l'heure ?
Thomas : On était pas en France tout à l'heure ?
Iris : On était au Pays de Galle !
Thomas : Ben c'est en France.
Iris : C'EST AU ROYAUME-UNI !
Thomas : Haaaaan... Et France Gall alors ?
[Bruit de machine temporelle]
Femme : Famille héritière de-
Thomas : Oh regardez y'a quelqu'un qui vient de se téléporter devant nous ! (- Sacrebleu ! Où-suis-je ?)
Elle me dit quelque chose.
Iris : C'est la voleuse de ma machine ! (Thomas : Ah oui ça me revient.)
Aliénor ! Rends moi ma machine !
Aliénor : Où nous trouvons-nous Dame Iris ? Encore de la sorcellerie ?
Sommes-nous en Enfer ?
Eliott : Non, nous sommes à... Berlin.
Iris : Reprenez lui ma machine ! Sale voleuse !
Aliénor : Mais c'est vous qui avez volé mon trône avec votre sorcellerie !
Iris : Aliénor..
Aiénor : Et si c'est cet objet que vous convoitez tant..
Iris : Aliénor !
Aliénor : Alors je le garde et peut-être que vous-.. *se téléporte*
- Iris : Oh la connasse ! (Thomas : Ah ben elle est partie) Elle est repartie avec MA machine !
Thomas : N'empêche y'avait une chance sur combien pour qu'elle apparaisse devant nous, comme ça ?
Eliott : 100%. La machine est programmée pour revenir à son propriétaire.
Iris : La machine est en mode Shuffle. Elle voyage aléatoirement dans le temps et l'espace.
Mais elle va bien finir par revenir !
Et là, PAF ! On récupère ma putain de machine !
Thomas : J'ai rien compris ! Mais ça marche.
D'ailleurs Iris, qu'est-ce que tu faisais dans un château ?
Iris : On est obligés d'en parler maintenant ?
J'aime bien voyager.
Thomas : Mais moi aussi j'aime bien voyager mais quand je vais en Espagne je cherche pas à devenir le Pape !
Iris : C'est au Vatican.. Bon j'aime bien voyager
dans le temps. Mon père a inventé cette machine alors
ça fait un an que je change d'époque pour découvrir le monde. Comment t'expliquer
hmmm.. Imagine que je suis en Erasmus temporelle.
Eliott : La trace du Docteur Simon est très faible.
C'est très difficile de le localiser.
Iris : Oh merde ! Ça nous arrange pas du tout ça..
On est comme des cons sous les bombardements des Américains.
Petit garçon : Excusez-moi ?
Thomas : Qui a parlé là ?
Iris : Baisse les yeux, c'est un petit garçon.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ici mon chou ?
C'est dangereux hein, il y a des bombes qui tombent du ciel.
Petit garçon : Je suis perdu...
Je cherche mes parents.
Eliott : Où les as-tu vu pour la dernière fois ?
Petit garçon : Dans un train. J'étais avec mes parents et mon papi.
Iris : Euh... Attends, tu viens d'où exactement ?
Petit garçon : Bah, de France.
On est montés dans un train, la SNCF était gentille, c'était gratuit.
Iris : Oh merde.
Thomas : La chance il prend le train gratos' !
Iris : Non, pas "la chance" du tout non.
Toute une famille dans un train direction l'Est dans les années 40, ça te rappelle rien ?
Thomas : Vu comme tu le dis, ça.. ça devrait ?
Eliott : L'Holocauste Thomas. C'est dans Call of Duty.
Thomas : Aaah.. Mais je regarde pas les cinématiques c'est pour ça.
Iris : Mais comment j'ai pu sortir avec toi ?
Bon écoute mon petit. On sait pas où sont tes parents.
Mais reste près de nous, tu seras plus en sécurité.
Petit garçon : Je vais retrouver ma famille ?
Eliott : Le risque qu'ils soient encore en vie est proche de.. 0-..
Iris : Ben oui..! Ils vont bien ! Ils vont bien chéri.
Petit garçon : Merci vous êtes gentils !
Pas comme le monsieur de tout à l'heure...
Iris : Ah oui, fais attention aux soldats hein, ils peuvent être très méchants envers euh...
Toi et.. ton peuple.
Petit garçon : C'était un monsieur bizarre avec une blouse blanche.
Qui est apparu comme par magie !
Il m'a posé des questions et après, il m'a laissé tout seul ici.
Eliott : Ça ressemble à la description du Docteur Simon.
Petit enfant, est-ce que c'est lui ? *montre une photo*
Petit garçon : Oui, c'est ça !
Iris : C'est mon père !
Génial on va pouvoir le retrouver !
Eliott : Hmm... Intéressant. Ton père abandonne les enfants juifs ?
Iris : Oui ben ça va hein.. Il avait la tête ailleurs. Enfin je crois.
Alors, dis nous où il est allé, le monsieur ?
Petit garçon : Là-bas !
Dans le grand bâtiment avec les grandes croix !
Eliott : Très bien. C'est un QG nazi. Rendons-nous là-bas.
Petit garçon : Super ! Allons-y !
Iris : Euh... Je suis pas sûre que ce soit l'endroit idéal pour toi chéri.
Thomas : D'accord. Donc on le laisse sous les bombes alors.
Iris : Oui bon ça va hein !
Allez viens petit reste avec nous. Mais fais-toi discret !
Petit garçon : Oui madame !
(Musique)
Iris : Avec un peu de chance, mon père est encore là-bas.
Petit garçon : Au début, il était très gentil, comme vous.
Et après il était méchant, il m'a frappé...
Thomas : Tu as dû avoir une enfance difficile et ???
Dis-moi mon petit... Il t'as fait des attouchements ?
Petit garçon : Des quoi ?
Iris : Mais mon père ne ferai jamais ça ! N'importe quoi..
On est arrivé. Cachez vous derrière les débris.
Oh merde... Mais pourquoi mon père est venu dans un QG nazi ? C'est infesté de soldats !
Petit garçon : Aller on y va ! *se met à courir*
Iris : Mais non ! Viens viens viens viens ! Petit reste ici !
Thomas : Reviens ! Reviens y'a des soldats partout ! (- Hey ! Hey papa !)
Eliott : Il va pouvoir retrouver sa famille... dans les cieux.
Iris : Arrête hein, c'est tellement triste...
Homme : Ah Lucien, mais où étais-tu passé ? (Iris : Mais attend...)
Lucien : T'as vu papi ? (Iris : le gamin est en train de discuter avec les soldats !)
Iris : Ils le prennent dans leurs bras ?!
*rire du petit garçon* Eliott : Ah oui, le soldat l'a mit sur son dos. Il fait du dada.
Thomas : Ça se passe très bien pour lui finalement.
Lucien : J'ai emmené des copains ! Tu veux que je te les présente ? Ils sont là-bas !
Eliott : Oh ! Ils viennent vers nous.
Lucien : Et voilà mes copains !
Homme : Très bien mon petit Lucien ! Vous pouvez entrer, faites comme chez vous.
On est de la même famille.
Thomas : Euh.. Non, je pense pas qu'on soit de la même-...
Homme : Lucien, va retrouver tes parents, ils sont dans le QG.
Lucien : Oui !
Homme : Mais ne va pas déranger papi. Il a une réunion très importante.
Entrez chers amis ! HEIL HITLER !
Lucien : Heil Hitler !
Iris et Thomas : Heil Himfff... *bafouillages*
(Musique)
Lucien : Merci de m'avoir aidé à retrouver mes parents !
Iris : Euh petit ? Tu viens d'où exactement en France ?
Lucien : De la capitale !
Iris : Paris ?
Lucien : Vichy !
Eliott : Mais il fait quoi ton papi ?
Lucien : Il est maréchal, c'est le Maréchal Pétain ! Vous connaissez ?
Iris : Oh putain..!
Thomas : Whaou. Si seulement je savais qui c'est.
Eliott : Du coup mon petit, tu n'es pas juif ?
Lucien : Pff. N'importe quoi ! Ma race est supérieure !
Iris : Ah bah nickel ! On est tombé sur un enfant nazi.
Bon écoute Lucien hummmm... Pétain.
Les Hommes sont tous égaux, il n'y a pas de race supérieure.
Lucien : Non ! C'est pas vrai !
Iris : Lucien, dis pas des bêtises !
Lucien : Non ! Je dis pas des bêtises !
En attendant, moi je sais où il est le monsieur avec la blouse...
Iris : C'est vrai ?! Dis nous !
Lucien : Alors dites : "La race aryenne est supérieure." Et je vous dis où il est.
Eliott : Très bien. La race aryenne est-...
Iris : Eliott ! Ne dis pas n'importe quoi !
Eliott : Il suffit de dire ça, et il nous donne l'information.
Iris : Non ! On dira jamais ça non ! C'est raciste !
Lucien : Non ! C'est vous les nuls ! Vous saurez jamais que le monsieur il est allé dans la bibliothèque !
Huh ! Oubliez ça !
Iris : La bibilothèque ?
Lucien : Ne partez pas ! Gardes !! Des juifs ! Ils-.. (Iris : Ta gueule !) *se fait assomer par Iris*
Thomas : Bravo Iris, tu viens d’assommer un enfant. C'est de famille on dirait.
Iris : Arrête tes conneries... Déjà que j'aime pas les enfants, mais alors les enfants nazis...
Cassons-nous avant que les gardes débarquent !
Eliott : La bibliothèque est à l'étage. Le Docteur Simon s'y trouve peut-être encore.
(Musique)
Iris : Là ! La porte de la bibliothèque ! Thomas tu fais quoi ?
Thomas : Ah ben je me recoiffe, c'est tout. Nan mais euh c'est pour faire bonne impression, 'fin je sais pas c'est ton père, quand même
à un moment faut être un peu présentable...
Iris : On est plus ensemble, Thomas !
Thomas : Alors c'était pas du tout pour toi du tout hein c'était juste euh...
Eliott : On rentre
Thomas : Bah voilà... Peut-être que... *ouvre la porte*
Homme : Was ?! (quoi en Allemand)
Iris : Oh putain..!
Homme : Encore des intrus dans ma bibliothèque ?!
Iris : C'est Hitler...!
Thomas : Attend mais.. Ton père c'est Hitler ?
Narrateur : Comment ça ? Adolph Hitler est le père d'Iris ?
Pas du tout mais alors pas du tout ! C'est un hasard !
Oui en Allemagne en 1944 on peut tomber sur Hitler.
C'est un fait.
Mais nos personnages..
Se rapprochent-ils ou s'éloignent-ils du Docteur Simon ?
Chaud ? Froid ? Tiède ?
Vous n'allez pas le croire ! Mais moi, je le sais.
Ah si vous êtes au courant... Vous savez que je savais.....
Cyprien : Merci d'avoir écouté le troisième épisode de "L'Épopée Temporelle",
N'hésite pas à t'abonner et à mettre un pouce en l'air, et à la semaine prochaine ! #Jambon